[Music]
tariq is one of the most legendary
competitors in north american
counter-strike history he was the
linchpin of na's only major winning
roster it is a dance and now they
concede multiple angles turret going
takes all the fights are down daddy not
11 hp reigns peaks and he gets the angle
now superior angle is there at the fuse
for the ct side the nine just yet
they're spamming the grenades they're
touching the bomb and now goes brain
another bomb that is trying to defuse it
again but no guardian gets taken down
absolutely unreal ranked cloud9 but
despite being a major mvp tarik isn't
only known for his skill in the server
he's also known for well
this
boots here come on yeah i'm blowing my
bun
blind my boy
dead
good [ __ ] round
shirt tv to peanut brain to the content
king tarik is one of the faces of first
person shooters on twitch
oh yeah oh yeah
back on the braces that's why i have the
top aces in fpl i might have the most
losses but i have the most aces you may
have just met him as his valorant
streams have become a safe haven for the
fps inclined where they can laugh
learn and kick back all night long
just let someone get it
[Music]
but make no mistake whether it's
valorant or counter-strike on stream or
on stage tariq has left his mark forever
and this
is his story
[Music]
at only 25 years old tariq chellik had
accomplished more than most players
could ever dream of his journey in
gaming started at a young age as a kid
tarik's father introduced him and his
brother to video games and they were
instantly hooked but as his older
brother tamer started getting into valve
titles like half-life and counter-strike
tariq wanted to join in tariq was like a
shadow
he wanted to hang out with his older
brother a lot
i would just stand there for hours i
don't even have a chair maybe like get a
glimpse of his headphones and like hear
what they're saying he's like four years
old five years old and shouldn't really
be watching me blow up people's brains
on a tv screen from that point on tarik
knew that he wanted to be a professional
counter-strike competitor he spent his
teenage years grinding cs source and
eventually picked up cs go when it was
released in 2012. he continued to grind
cs go against his parents wishes and by
the time he turned 18 he landed his
first pro contract with a team called
netcode guides in july 2014 but just as
they were starting to make a name for
themselves the organization announced
that they were closing their cs go
division luckily the roster wasn't on
the market too long and they joined
mouse spaz almost immediately after the
release their strong performances in the
n a scene then allowed the team to get
acquired by a bigger org counter logic
gaming under clg tariq managed to win
some small events and when he had the
opportunity to play live on stage he
always made sure to rep his family's
turkish heritage i remember like asking
my mom to bring something for me
anything that represented my nationality
i gave tariq a scarf i was expecting a
flag so it was more like i was walking
out with a scarf like this it was
different but i think it was cool still
and it showed what i was going for
everyone saw it and all the cameras
caught it but in the server clg was
struggling every time they had an
opportunity to represent n a at cs go's
major championships they failed to show
up so in july of 2016 tariq returned to
one of his true passions streaming
oh my god
since the early days of nacs he could be
found clowning around on twitch and
making his viewers laugh and he would
often do all of this while shirtless
which became a bit of a calling card so
his break from competitive play didn't
necessarily come as a surprise but when
optic decided to temporarily bench
stanislaw in august of 2016 tariq was
given another opportunity to compete
forcing him to put his content creation
goals on hold within a few months tariq
helped prove that optic were na's best
and by the end of the year
they shocked everyone to stop the
terrorists from getting out there so
quickly
again tarik not respecting this is the
key here is that optic are showing no
respect for phase now we can see if they
could win a pistol round here tarrick
got to get a good headshot in and he
spotted a lot of other people he's
already got the information that this is
a real a push there's no fake into this
here it's another one takes out hazy
napoli is going to be going down but
terry he can't be stopped he's looking
for more he's going to get the quad kill
i can't believe it's
oh and six they're trailing and it's
pistols here along with the fights in
the gate of the p zip is getting caught
and tarik what is that that spray
transfer
so sick it's going to be champion glaive
left with over a minute but in a two on
four spray comes through rush gets a
kill and ladies and gentlemen up to
gaming your winners of e-league season
two
they rounded out the year with a second
place finish at the ecs season two
finals but once the atlanta major rolled
around in january of 2017 the team
crashed out in the group stage after
months of poor performances optic
mustered up a top 8 finish at cologne
2017 and this proved to be tarik's last
event with the roster but after helping
put north american counter-strike on the
map other orgs began taking notice of
him and as cloud 9 entered a rebuilding
phase tarik joined the team alongside
rush in august of 2017. early on he
decided to take the reigns as the team's
in-game leader and within a few months
cloud9 was taking home trophies cloud9
ladies and gentlemen we'll be your
victors here at the i buy power masters
2017. outside of the server tarek was
continuing to build his community on
twitch his relationship with his new
teammates helped spawn a culture of
memes that still endure to this day
[Laughter]
by the time the boston major rolled
around at the start of 2018 cloud9 were
widely considered to be the best team in
north america they breezed their way
through the new challenger stage but
once the legend stage was underway
things didn't exactly go as planned
after losing their opening two matches
it was do or die for cena but with their
tournament lives on the line tariq and
his team showed up plays through the
smoke automatic hearing them executing
snags and there's the last player
patcher in the red and cloud9 are
fighting for survival that's high
grounder oh they spotted him they
definitely knew and there's the kill
16-6 australia set packing from cloud9
who continue into the tournament
entirely 180 again though the hpi jumps
across rush nails at 16.
rounds for cloud nine playing on home
soil cloud9 quickly started to look
unstoppable they dominated g2 in a swift
2-0 to earn themselves a spot in the
semi-finals but things weren't going to
get easier from there because awaiting
them in the semis were the brazilian
powerhouse two-time major winners sk
gaming cloud9 shocked everyone by taking
map one on mirage in convincing fashion
but on map two
sk bounced back stewie with the triple
looking for the quad there's gonna be a
single click they're not really working
out now he's out of the open before
playing with him taking him down it
can't be any better than that
closing out the map is for sixteen eight
in freyro sk gaming and we're gonna go
to map number three of the semifinals
there was one map keeping tarik and c9
from becoming only the second north
american team to ever make the grand
finals of a major
cloud nine answering back twice as hard
taking down
automatic with the kill
and just like that
clown nine in a one versus four
taco can't do anything the pandemonium
in 16 rounds and cloud9 are in the grand
finals of a major tournament
awaiting them in that final were none
other than faze clan faze were a super
team built to win titles this was
supposed to be their moment
their major and despite cloud9 having
the home crowd advantage the series
didn't exactly start out in their favor
automatic on his own running up to short
position i think olaf might have heard
him which means that they can all hold
angles the smoke fake the flashback
won't work out faith clan take the first
map of this series faze were one map
away from hoisting the major trophy that
everyone expected them to hoist but
tarek and c9 weren't willing to go down
without a fight shots doing a quick rip
of a second just break down a garden
hose although dead five rounds for cloud
nine since the absolute beginning of
this team carrigan leaving australis
turret
as well he's got a lot to prove and he's
trying to do so relentless aggression
doesn't matter what the situation oh
that's dirty but it is from street uk
and tarik finishes things off he's
popping off waits patiently
[Applause]
cloud9 took overpass 16 to 10 to force
the grand final to a third and final map
they managed to get off to a hot start
winning five out of the first six rounds
but faze bounced back and in the second
half they started to pull away funnily
enough because turret has no kevlar
reign has a very good chance of taking
him out and there he is some bonus money
made by rayne lots of smg kills and that
means more pressure to come from faze
clan who are five rounds away from
winning this major they cannot win this
they've got to run away they have to run
away they've got all the kills but they
win win the round it's match point faith
with faze one round away from winning
the major cloud nine needed a miracle
and thankfully in round 30
stewie gave it to them stewie's on his
own but look at the time look at the
time there's seven seconds of blood up
they're trying to build pyramids but
there's no more play
stewie's walking around we're going
[Applause]
but tarek and c9 didn't stop there it is
a dance and now they concede multiple
angles territory takes all the fights
for down daddy not eleven hp reigns
peaks and he gets the angle now superior
angle is there at the fuse for the ct
side the nine they just yet they're
spamming the grenades they're touching
the bomb and now goes rain another bomb
is trying to defuse it again but no
guardian gets taken down absolutely
unreal ran from cloud nine
and uh they're gonna hust him anyway so
there it is
cloud nine take a one-round lead
guardian waits
patiently as cloud9 sets the push up oh
oh it's happened they made it work cloud
nine are your league major champions
cloud nine became north america's first
and only major champions and tarek was
named mvp of the major with a 1.43
rating in the grand final after years of
hard work he had finally reached the top
of the counter-strike world but what
came next surprised everyone
when the dust settled from their
historic victory
c9 started to fall apart skadoodle
stepped down from the team and stewie
left to join sk taric stuck around for a
few months but wasn't able to recreate
their previous success so in july of
2018 he announced that he was joining
mibr and reuniting with stu joining this
team was a really hard step for me to
take because it was actually my decision
and i reached out to mibr and i asked
them if they would be interested it was
really hard for me because leaving
cloud9 a great organization a great team
my friends who i've played with for a
really long time it wasn't easy but this
is a very unique opportunity to be able
to play with some of the greats in
counter-strike and i felt that you know
i had to like try to push myself to keep
going forward unfortunately tarek didn't
exactly find the success that he was
hoping for with mibr they exited the
london major in the semis and watched
astralis lift their second major trophy
after more mediocre results followed
mibr decided to return to a fully
brazilian lineup leaving tariq without a
team but it also gave him time to
refocus on content creation
i don't know
was in there
that's what i'm talking about that's
what i'm talking about in february of
2019 he was unveiled as the newest
member of nrg's up-and-coming cs roster
almost immediately they looked like a
top team and after a top four finish at
the berlin major even more eyes were
drawn to them just a few weeks later
evil geniuses signed the entire roster
eg knew that these guys were capable of
beating the world's best teams and at
their first event under their new org
they proved it this should be g2's first
and it's evil geniuses and tariq could
do damage they are he said
and it's a massacre
this is what you're wondering this was
your second question what do you do now
great you got the frag 10 seconds and
you're walking straight into breezy 1v1
ethan to finish evil geniuses will take
the grand final with astralis in new
york tomorrow and they start to dive
towards tt and that's their big
connection tara comes to claim as well
they're locked out ct but tariq wants to
bring the point
also the fact they're on the t side they
have to make the plays to start the play
oh
no
the boy from brooklyn does it on home
soil in the barclays
and eg
they let train slip away but they don't
make the same mistake on luke
it's luke no less australia's forcing a
dynasty on that map in ikea
they've done it here in new york tariq
and eg took down the major champs in new
york before winning star series season 8
the following month they cemented
themselves as one of the best teams in
the world finishing fourth in hltv's
team of the year rankings but as the
covet 19 pandemic forced cs into an
online era at the start of 2020 eg
really started to fall off and in april
of 2021 tariq announced that he would be
stepping down from eg's active roster to
focus on streaming
and content creation the content king
was back he returned to twitch with some
counter-strike action like everyone
expected but a new game had taken the
platform by storm while he was gone and
with many of his north american friends
already streaming valorant tarik decided
to start mixing it into his schedule
almost immediately the valorent
community welcomed tarik with open arms
his humor and good vibes were infectious
and he brought something to the
community that not many streamers could
tarek is the type of individual that
whenever he streams or even within his
team he has credible ability to turn any
situation into a positive anything you
do or anything he's a part of it doesn't
matter what the hell it is and this is
what makes him such a good streamer and
it's what made him such a great teammate
as well is any situation derek has an
answer for it or a way to like not even
make you laugh but just make the
situation not feel
like you're drowning in it or something
like that now to have him invalorent he
brings like a lot of humor he's just a
good personality to have he brings like
a another side of viewership to na so i
just think overall he's like a great
addition to the valerian scene tarek
entered the valorem scene at the perfect
time as the valor champions tour circuit
started to ramp up it gave him the
opportunity to host his own watch
parties where tens of thousands of
viewers would gather to hear him share
his thoughts on the game
[Music]
[Applause]
but there are a couple of important
things to know about tara extreme first
off he's a bit of a sellout wait this
looks so trippy
you want to subscribe to me
you have a twitch prime subscription
you're thinking about who you should use
it on
that person could be me
fun that person could be someone else
weigh your options carefully but the
single most important thing to know
about tarek is that he adores tens
river straight dog
lens uses that op
okay why don't you say that in the first
place i heck and love tens
hey guys uh this is tara from n a ranked
q um i just wanted to ask shazam i have
two questions for you my first question
is uh who are your favorites for the
event and my second question is do you
heck and love tens
that chest um
favorites i'd say us game bits are given
um nv2 they're the guys that beat us
last time and that just i can love 10.
let's go let's go
bolstered by the popularity of valorant
itself tarik's stream has blown up he's
one of the biggest content creators on
twitch peaking at over 13 000
subscribers he's managed to crack the
code and unite both the valorant and cs
community something that most people
would have never thought was possible
tariq was like you know one of the like
kings of content and having him come to
valerian you know valorant content i
think it's a great thing for valentine
it's also a great thing for the
relationship between valor and cs go
because i know there's a lot of hate
between the two a lot of rivalries and
whatnot but then like having such a big
streamer come over and play both kind of
shows like hey we can co-exist like this
guy such a big role model streamer is
enjoying both csgo and valerie and
killing it in both
right so i think
yeah i think he's a great addition to
the ballerina community and although
there are those who would still like to
see him make a return to competitive
counter-strike right now
he just wants to see how far streaming
can take him
between me and you guys in the chat
that he's probably gonna keep
honestly competing super fun
it is super fun but
i've done it for a super long time as
well and with covet has kind of given me
an opportunity to try it out
also luckily enough while i was with eg
so kind of things worked out on its own
they're in your strength 30 seconds left
what's backside
yeah it's hyper aware
as a guardian
i know i know i know i know i know i
know i know
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this hit the sub button and
ring the notification bell for unique
bite-sized videos you won't find
anywhere else hit up our twitter
instagram facebook and tick tock